talk a little bit about China we've had
commentary from various car-making CEOs
this morning talking about just how
quickly things are slowing in China give
us your thoughts yeah overall i guess
nobody could protect really this kind of
new normal that fast nevertheless if
China is still the biggest market for
the automotive business it's still 24
millions of cars per year and if the GDP
goes wrong down to five percent it's
still at around about 500 million and
therefore it's the size of Belgium which
can be added year by year to the Chinese
economy and therefore we will sell out
the vehicles in China in the future but
in the near term how are you managing it
what is the the near-term story
long-term great but short-term shot them
we have a very new and a fantastic
product line and we are just building up
at this very moment our local production
in our new plant in China so we have a
good opportunity based on our very very
small market share we are niche player
but we are the channeling alternative
really to come up again and also to
increase our volume in China you've
launched a Jaguar SUV um this is the
first one I understand you wish you've
done it sooner yes it's the very first
check or a crossover with a complete DNA
of a checkers a very sporty very drive
active and at the end of the day very
very safe based on lightweight aluminium
technology and how do you think that's
gonna sell in the States and do you
worry about what's going to happen in
the US market which has been doing so
strongly you built a car for it and now
it could slow down yes absolutely the
u.s. is strong and we also can grow in
the US we have a very good product
lineup for the US and there
we are quite sure that we can attract
customers in u.s. how will you do that
dr. Spath because it's a crowded market
the SUV market is crowded in the US as
elsewhere yes a SUV market it's crowded
but at the end of the day although this
is the fastest growing segment in the
automotive industry we are niche player
but we really offer something different
something special and therefore not just
the product we also offer our customers
a lifestyle and that been make the
difference for our customers what
happens if the Federal Reserve starts
raising interest rates US car buyers
tend to finance them there is an effect
does that concern you is that built into
your numbers right now we don't know how
customers will react nobody can predict
the future nevertheless I based on a
very very strong product portfolio I
guess we can continue our way in u.s.
connected cars and technology in cars
has been something that's been talked
about for a few years at these auto
shows doctors method are you tempted to
go into joint ventures around the
technology theme are you being tempted
into joint ventures some of the big
technology players might be interested
in that yeah the customer attitude the
customer demand is changing permanently
and based on this change we also dropped
and proactively introduced new
technology think about the new in touch
pro our new infotainment system which
has got twice the line code of lines
which a triple seven Dreamliner has
there you can see already the power of a
new infotainment system just an
infotainment system has got twice the
power of a triple server isn't it
fantastic assuming that I can figure out
how to make it work yes that probably is
the case i was in to struggle with those
days
why yeah it's an issue believe you me
why why why would I by an SUV from from
from Jaguar when when you've got a
really good one that's been around for
quite long a quite a long time and it's
called the Range Rover by the way you
get the very best the SUV's on the land
rover and range rover side that goes
with is without question but now you
have got an alternative there's no
competition in between it's a con it
just really fits together nicely there's
hardly an overlap and you get a DNA
crossover from checker a fantastic
product dr. Smith you're obviously there
to sell your own cars but have you seen
anything else that's caught your eye are
you impressed by anything that any of
the other car makers are doing and the
motor show is going to open in some
hours only and ever I haven't seen
anything so far but I can show you an
hour stand you see the Range Rover from
our special operation in the
autobiography division and there you can
see a very stunning SUV